ExxonMobil shareholders voted for the
14th consecutive year to reject a
resolution that would have added
non-discrimination protections for their
LGBT employees I mean what really is
that 14 years in a row guys what are you
doing Fred I know this is right in your
wheelhouse you've been an LGBT activist
for a long time you've taken on exon
amongst many other companies where does
this come from how in 2013 with all the
progress are they as a bunch of stodgy
white men that's what I picture them as
sitting in an office and going no not
gonna you know we're gonna keep
discriminating against the gays I have
one word Texas yeah they're Texas based
you know largest company in the
corporation in the world kind of goes
back and forth but when they took over
mobile which had a good track record on
LGBT rights they they threw those out
and kept their discrimination and they a
Human Rights Campaign the largest LGBT
political organization rates the top
thousand corporations in the US and from
a zero to one hundred well now they've
given exxon mobil a 25 - I have the
negative so yeah I did a commercial I
took on Exxon Mobil for a very good
reason when I was actually campaigning
about a year ago not only because of
their abysmal civil rights record but
because of their gas pricing and gouging
of the American public which hurt our
economy and we need to get aggressive
against these companies I've been
leading a boycott of Amway because they
gave half a million dollars to take away
gay marriage and states all over the
country I think we need to boycott
companies like Exxon they are nine point
eight billion dollars in the first
quarter of the year an astronomical
amount of money but if we can hit them
in the pocketbook I think we will get
them to come around and do the right
thing
yeah is money and boycotting like what
what's going on here is that the only
way we can affect these guys because
they seem to only care about money right
this is is this about trying I'm trying
to do what they view as the right thing
yeah like I can boycott you know I'll
try real hard to boycott but I don't
think everyone's gonna boycott you know
right mobile I mean the thing you can do
you can't say like don't don't visit
Exxon Mobil you know get I guess you
actually you can say listen you're at a
corner there's three gas stations just
don't go to that one right with that go
to boo because they're all they're doing
all yeah so what are we good we're gonna
try to like check off the ones that
haven't totally screwed people up yet
right
she'll I think they're okay I love it I
love that berkshire hathaway feed our
exxon mobil by scoring zero points right
this is that bonkers it's insane
so what do we do here because right
you're not gonna look i so a few couple
people that are for gay rights not going
Exxon all right fine
but is this just like one of these
things where corporations it's like
Walmart dumping you know tons of stuff
into the ocean and then paying an eighty
million dollar fine it means nothing to
them like is this sort of like we just
can't stop these guys we are everyone go
out there and boycott Exxon Mobil but I
just like thinking about it in terms of
of you're voting it's not like you're
not voting for it you're literally
voting against it but if to say come on
it's so fun to discriminate against gay
people yeah that's our one thing let's
let it just let us do it yeah so what is
going on in these boardrooms when they
are voting because as Brett saying they
are literally sitting there and deciding
whether this is not part of a bigger
issue what are they saying
what are they actually saying like this
is our one little secret they don't care
about their employees and their
customers and it's an insult in 2013 to
do this and it's intolerable and I say
we go after these companies I did for
boycotts during the prop 8 campaign we
ended up settling three of those with
major donors to the other side six
figures and up and so we need to put
pressure on these go across the street
to Chevron prices usually a little
cheaper than Mobil and support our
friends and don't support the enemies of
equality and I'm a firm believer in that
I'm not organizing a boycott against X
mo but I did a very effective commercial
which got a huge number of views I call
their chairman Rex Tillerson
Tyrannosaurus Rex because he is living
in the dark ages and we need to get some
pressure on these companies to do the
right thing and it's working these are
looking to brag that they have a hundred
on HRC now yeah and I want to get Exxon
Mobil from minus 25 up to 100 is part of
the problem here
it's the government because you know we
couldn't pass the employee
non-discrimination Act and not that I
want the government jumping in on
everything but if we could have got that
passed then they wouldn't be allowed to
get away with something yes I mean if
you force people to do this kind of
thing then yes they will do it and I
think that there are plenty of other you
know legislative initiatives that have
passed in order to move the football
down the field and try to advance the
cause it's just one of those things
where you look at it and you're just
like I am shocked like who are these
people
yeah what are they doing do they have
the ever met a gay person yeah and I
mean a lot of they're a lot of their
defenses you know there are other
portions of our training videos where we
say that people should not discriminate
against gay it's just it is so simple
for you guys to just sit around have
this vote change it and don't tell
anyone and then a year later tell people
that you changed it just do it and then
no one will have any reason to go
complain about you are they on the other
hand just like really vying for that
like anti gay consumer right it's just
like you know listen I have this pump
phallus and I'm putting it into my
Yannick tank and I just want to do that
yeah you know well I think you're right
that it's like they never get screwed
you know to me in there there used to
always getting what they want and
reaping tons of profits from it so it's
like for them to cave to the gays right
about a little saying would be so
catastrophic in their minds because they
run the show when it comes to public
policy and politics their profits are
just astronomical and we need to keep
the pressure on them in the pocketbook
where it hurts and I'm convinced they
will come around like all these other
companies you know Sachs which has of
course a huge number of LGBT associates
that call up and certainly customers in
New York and Beverly Hills in San
Francisco they have a zero rating with
the HRC too I think it's important to
get that information out right so people
know don't go to Saks go to
Bloomingdale's that has a ninety or go
to Nordstrom's that has a hundred I'd
much rather support our friends and I
think that's important and there's
there's no company that's too big to to
boycott yeah and I'm pretty sure Saks
has a couple game play
you think there might be one or two
there yeah
it's there's no monetary benefit for
them to to have this policy you know
there's only monetary negative fallout
yeah you know no one I don't think
anyone's flocking to them because they
hate gay people so by just puzzling
Ben's department exon do it for the
money if nothing else if that's all you
guys